I knew
that the captain is the Brazilian team
who beat European clubs the most?
historic posters,
as four to three against Real Madrid,
first victory for a South American
against a European champion
won the Paris tournament title in fifty-seven,
one of the two intercontinentals that the championship has,
seven to two against Barcelona.
This match
happened a few days after the victory
about Real Madrid.
It was,
for a long time,
the biggest defeat of the Catalan team
in international duels,
acting within their domains,
three to one against Manchester United in the world cup.
The match took place at Maracanã,
during the two thousand world championship,
and the giant won
with the show by the duo Edmundo and Romário
and the one-nil against Ajax,
the last game of the championship against Europeans
what happened in two thousand and thirteen
and marked the farewell of the idol Pedrinho.